I don't want to look back on any body of
music and be like you know what I gave
that one 70 hmm
that one was 85. I want to look back and
be like you know what
that was the best version of me in that
moment
that's what I'm striving for and I'm
competing against other people too but
that's more the ego when I'm in my core
my best version of myself I'm trying to
capture the cosmos I'm trying to capture
something that is much bigger than me
that you cannot put into words like that
intangible spirit that flows through you
every once in a while that's what I'm
trying to capture yeah and the only way
that I can get there is if I free myself
of any sort of
trying to control the outcome I just let
it be and then the music writes it